[Music]
good to see you thank you for coming out
Thanks wish things had me out I'm
excited to talk to you again I want to
preface this by saying if you have not
listened to our first conversation
definitely maybe even hit pause now and
go back and listen to that I never go
back and listen to old episodes but in
the case of you probably mostly because
I'm intimidated by you I did go back and
like wrap my head around what we talked
about last time I was like well how we
covered a lot in that right like we went
and we kind of went through the whole
thing and I don't want to replicate too
much of that but I'm excited to kind of
extrapolate on what we spoke about last
time so welcome thanks sounds good
you were with you were over doing let's
work out this morning right I was it was
brutal so walk me through it oh well
first of all how'd that come together um
it was through mutual friends was such a
bunch of us that have known about this
for a while the mythic Laird Hamilton
morning pool workout uh right so I I
remember hearing what it was like and
thinking I really hope I never have to
do that and and actually I was right it
was it was brutal but but I do feel
really good now I'm actually uh they say
it's it's good for your mind as well and
I can see why I'm now just grateful to
be alive yeah so what that's like is if
if listeners don't know is you you start
out in a really hot sauna and I'm not
just saying a hot sauna it's like this
temperature of the surface of the Sun
yeah so I normally do a hundred sixty
degrees at my own gym this thing was
cranked up beyond 250 it was most high I
knew I knew he said it around 200 I
didn't realize it was that hot Wow
yeah it's at the point where I was
getting pretty dizzy so you do that and
then you jump into the you have a shower
jumping in the pool
and you grab well first of all you swim
underwater and tell you basically out of
breath and you want to pass out then
they give you weights and then you've
got you go into the deep end you're
underwater below the top of your head by
you know maybe a foot and then
have to jump up and down and you think
okay I can do that
there are two problems one is if you
don't make it you're gonna take in a
mouthful of water which is what I did of
course the first thing and then the
other problem is you go into this panic
mode I don't know if anyone who's ever
experienced what it's like to drown but
now I know what it's like to drown it is
not pleasant you you always let go of
the weight and surface there is that but
but there's only one think there's Laird
standing there and try judgment of Laird
yeah I would rather drown than embarrass
and give up so you know I looked like a
stupid fish well a land animal in water
for a while I actually found out that I
probably shouldn't have gone so far into
the deep end mmm that was my first
mistake but then what do we do we also
warmed up again in the sauna and then we
jumped into a big bathtub with ice with
about a couple of inches of ice on the
top and that wasn't so bad you know I've
talked about cryotherapy before and
saunas and hypoxia but I've never done
it so extreme you know I know where
offers is the guide of beat but I
usually go to my gym which is just 4
degrees Celsius I don't know what that
isn't in Fahrenheit but it's not that
cold as far your frigid temperature and
I found that brutal but actually going
into that ice water
I was I was fine I mean the initial
shock like I can't breathe I'm gonna
yeah and then but maybe 15 seconds later
with Gabby Reece telling me breathe
slowly breathe slowly feel the heat
rather than the cold you can convince
yourself that you're warm in this
freezing cold temperature it actually
was great and I got to three minutes as
she was gonna do two minutes because she
thought I was a bit of a a wimp got to
three minutes and thought I could just
keep going this isn't so bad no pouring
ice on my head at that point were you up
to your neck oh yeah I actually went on
to a couple of times Oh huh that's great
and then you get out and you feel great
you feel refreshed grateful to be alive
and yeah I would do it again in a second
uh-huh how many how many people were
there this morning
there were about ten of us yeah I've got
I have friends that go to that workout
and I've had it I've had a kind of a you
know sort of an open invite to drop I
mean I kind of do my own that my own
workout and it's a bit of a drive for me
so I haven't made it over there but also
in frankness like I'm scared to like you
know I mean like but what I've what I've
heard was Darren Eileen there this
morning
he's a sort of a layered look-alike like
yeah Darren been on the podcast I'm very
good friend of mine Darren has said that
the people who fare well or the best are
generally the people that that go into
it with a healthy dose of humility
it's the problems arise when you get
these super alpha guys who think they're
you know basically invincible like
whether they're MMA fighters or Navy
SEALs or whatever and think that they
can do anything and kind of attack it
from a perspective of you know some kind
of dick measuring contest of like I'm
gonna do this better than Laird or
whatever and they're the ones who get
crushed and humiliated yeah there's a
bit of that today yeah yes it down and I
talked about he's interesting guy right
he's saucing yeah you guys they talk
forever
we we know we will meet up again good
and yeah the Justin Ren was there well
you know our friend Justin Rin that was
his first time doing it too
yeah and he was my buddy Sam I'm a
fighter exactly so Justin was a fight
foot of garden that's his charity
wonderful wonderful guy check him out he
was my buddy and first thing I asked him
when I was teamed up with him was do you
know CPR and especially need to rescue
me yeah that's cool well you did you do
I have this right like you have some
scientific background in thermogenesis
don't you did you do you know ray Crowe
nice did you work with him on some of
the studies that that he did on that or
papers to get right that's what I
thought yeah so right ray and I
interesting story he was a former NASA
scientist not even thinking about
metabolism or right or health at the
time he was overweight by his own
admission and I met him at a TEDMED talk
2008 it was and after my talk about
aging and longevity
we were there with quincy jones of all
people and he said David I've never
heard a talk that's convinced when he
you know to change my life I'm gonna do
what you do and I'm gonna be a disciple
now we thought okay you know ray will
you know see you later
uh-huh he did it and so now what is that
you know over 10 years later he has
changed his life he's he's a guru for
for health and particularly cold therapy
and we've published a couple of papers
one is on the metabolic winter
hypothesis the idea that you know these
days we always look for comfort and one
of the problems is we never experience
temperature variation in our lives we
will bundle up at night and we'll put on
a jacket to go outside and this is one
of the reasons we think that we all have
tendency to get metabolic defects as we
get older right Ray's now kind of
pivoted more into the nutrition
landscape she's got this new book out
with Juliana haver yeah hell span I
think it's called right helpful book
yeah I gave it to my wife for for the
holidays it cool yeah it's really great
I really liked those guys both of them
they make a good combination mmm because
Juliana is the the cook and yeah brain
yeah exactly it is it is a good mix they
live like right up the street here what
do they yeah they've been on the podcast
cool well I think it's interesting that
you you did the Laird and Gabi workout
this morning with this combination of
like sauna and ice baths so maybe a good
you know first thing to explore is the
relationship of those types of therapies
on aging and longevity right well the
bottom line is you've got to get out of
your comfort zone and get your body out
of its comfort zone hormesis is what we
call it right and the problem with
today's world is marketing branding our
own just our own primeval brain we just
want to be relaxed we want to be fed we
don't want to feel discomfort and that's
leading to a whole bunch of problems and
if we're not always telling our body
things that could be problematic our
bodies don't care they don't fight
against disease that aren't fight
against aging so
these treatments and these crazy things
that I did today are all about turning
on the the genes that we work on we
could talk about those in a minute but
this is the revolution that's happening
and there's a whole bunch of people your
listeners for example are realizing that
one of the biggest problems in our lives
is that we've just been you know handled
with kid gloves and the food we eat is
also not stressed out and that
combination just turns us into mush it's
interesting when you say the food that
we eat is not stressed out so that's
that's about kind of taking in stressed
foods to prompt this hormesis type
effect through our nutrition or you know
explain what you mean by that
right well we were working on
resveratrol the residual stories what I
first was known for in science world and
we discovered there a whole bunch of
different plant molecules one of them is
resveratrol from found in red wine but
there are a lot of others there's
quercetin from onions for example and
they all activate these longevity
enzymes that we have in our bodies and
they're found in plants as well and we
were trying to figure out why would it
be that these so-called polyphenolic
compounds like resveratrol and quercetin
why would our bodies benefit or why
would a mouse benefit by eating these
molecules and what we came up with was
the concept of Zeno hormesis Zeno means
between species and hormesis is what
doesn't kill you makes you stronger and
it's even though it's a mouthful what
what it explains so much is that when
our plants are stressed that we eat
we've probably evolved to sense when the
environment and our food supply is
running out or potentially running out
so if you're picking olives off a dry
you know hill or you're eating fruit
that's just had a massive drought you're
gonna have molecules in that food
that'll tell your body
hey these plants may not be around for
the next known month mm-hm and that was
our explanation and it really does make
a lot of sense and is fitting with a
whole bunch of
of data we've had over the last couple
of centuries that's like different
species communicating with each other
through some you know unheard language
it is it is and actually what it means
is a couple of things one is donate
foods that are grown on to perfect
conditions that works well for the
growers because they get food much more
quickly think of the lettuce that you
buy that's in the greenhouse that's
never been stressed is just watery white
and watery right avoid white and watery
what you want is denser colored food the
color is actually an indicator that
you've got these polyphenolic beneficial
molecules so I like to buy foods that
are locally grown organic and typically
grown in in conditions that are not
perfect so what is it about it being
locally grown or being organic that
enhances the hormesis impact or the
stress response in the plants like we
couldn't you could you figure out a
conventional way of growing food we're
at the last minute you stress them
before you pick them or something like
that so you're getting an enhancement of
those polyphenols or whatever it is that
you're looking for that's exactly right
that's what I think we should be doing
and there's a business idea okay any
facts Laird was telling me just an hour
ago that that I didn't know this that
people who grow oranges and know what
they're doing
drive a nail into the tree I think was a
day or so before they picked the fruit
and then gives it these extra well
that's that's interesting yeah so we got
to harm the plants just a little bit but
doesn't need to be all the time it can
be just before you pick them and think
about grapes all right what we do when
we want to have great wine is we pick
them just as their stress that we you
try to pick them when there hasn't been
rainfall for a little bit hmm and then
they fill up with these great tasting
molecules but also these xeno hormetic
molecules as well so how does that I
mean when when when we're told like
listen you should eat organic food it's
really about trying to avoid the
pesticides and everything else that gets
packed into conventionally grown foods
but what is what is it about Organic
that relates
well you know there's organic and
there's real organic I'm talking about
the plants that you know may have had a
grub eat it or are exposed to too much
sunlight that kind of thing being out in
rougher conditions yeah
I'm hyper organic right right all right
not Natsu that's the name of a new
company let's do it yeah that's cool
well when you look at Laird
I mean he's sort of a an experiment in
motion right like what is he fifty-five
now yeah thank doesn't look a day older
than he did you know ten fifteen years
ago and he's still killing it and I
would say that he's probably a pretty
good example of somebody who's
practicing a lot of the things that you
talk about I mean I don't know what his
you know supplement routine is with
respect to you know some of the research
that you're doing but in terms of his
daily exercise regimen and lifestyle
habits it seems to be you know to
comport with the things that you talk
about often yeah right he's the orange
tree with the name on it every day
but I totally believe it and you don't
just do it with hot and cold and you
don't just do it with what you eat there
are other things you can do like when
you eat you can also you need to have
plenty of exercise which is another
thing and one of the breakthroughs that
we've had in the longevity field is that
we used to think you know let's go back
20 years ago that exercise was something
that made your blood flow better and
make you healthier that eating less food
was healthy because it lowered
inflammation somehow what we've realized
is that all of these things are working
through the same mechanisms and it goes
back to work that we did in my lab in
yeast cells you know a little fungi that
we grow that we use for bread and beer
what we showed and this is go back to
2003 now is that there's one gene that
controls longevity it's got a name
called PN C one it makes this molecule
called nad which is very healthy turns
on defenses we found that these yeast
cells live longer when you gave them a
bit of stress so if you turn up the
incubator to 37 degrees Celsius and
serve 30 they live longer or you starve
them a little bit of or take away a
little bit of the amino acids in their
food
or what else could we do we could
restrict the amount of sugar that they
are eating that'll made them live longer
but it all worked through this one
genetic pathway and that was a
breakthrough at the time because you
know even today most people don't
realize that all of these things that we
do are converging on this master regular
regulatory pathway for our health mm-hmm
is that part and parcel of this you know
kind of singular information theory of
aging that is you know the sort of the
foundation of your work yeah it all
connects it's all slowly coming together
it's taken 30 years of work but we're
getting there I can see the end of the
tunnel and what what is interesting is
that so this nad molecule is the fuel
for a class of enzymes that acts like
the traffic cops in the cell they they
send out the troops to repair and fix
things and one of the main things they
do we found is they control the
expression or the control information in
the cell not not the genetic information
but in how the genetic information is
controlled mmm and these genes are
called sirtuins Saussure to ins you can
think of as the pianist that plays the
genetic piano mm-hmm and when they're
not active the penis becomes complacent
makes a lot of mistakes and ends up
becoming demented and that is what I
believe is a large driver of the aging
process hmm
but if you're always activating your
sirtuins the pianist keeps playing the
controller for much longer and you we
stay younger right we talked about this
last time the analogy we use wasn't the
pianist I know that's like the title of
I think the second chapter on the book
Yunus where you explain all of this the
the metaphor that we used was was you
know highway traffic right and and
getting dispatched you know away from
their their true role to kind of deal
with crises potholes in the roadway and
whatnot and then the signaling you know
getting screwed up and then basically
all of the kind of traffic copying going
haywire and these these you know the NAD
isn't going where it's supposed to go be
going and the sirtuins aren't where
they're supposed to be in the whole kind
of
system breaks down that's right and we
first discovered this I was at MIT as a
postdoc originally moved to Harvard in
1999 those years were were affirmative
what we discovered in yeast cells it's
incredible right you can learn from a
little fungus these big concepts these
sore tunes in the yeast cells were
maintaining the identity of those yeast
cells and making them stay young and
healthy for longer by keeping the gene
piano working for longer now what we
also realized was that you can distract
them from their main job the pianist can
get distracted you know imagine you know
you you start trying to you know whistle
or get in get in the face of your
pianist it's essentially the same and
what is a major distraction for these
sirtuins in a normal job is broken
chromosomes broken DNA DNA damage and we
know that DNA damage can accelerate
aging anyone who's lived in California
or Australia like we have knows that DNA
damage from the Sun will accelerate
aging but no one has ever fully
understood why and it's been a mystery
and mutations don't seem to be the main
driver unless as the old theory so what
I think is going on is that these breaks
in the chromosome is DNA damage is
distracting these sirtuins from
maintaining the symphony perfectly they
get distracted they go off and do stuff
fix the chromosome and then most of them
come back and keep playing the piano but
some of them never make it back to where
they should and over time that's
cumulative and you end up with a
cacophony so the goal the job the
mission is to maximize the efficiency to
really optimize this or two in
functionality right and the way to do
that is to make the body think that it's
it could run out of food or has to run
away from a saber-toothed tiger and that
all relates back to the activity of
these search because then they're not
distracted by these sort of frivolous
situations and they're they're focused
on the the most important job that
they're kind of created to deal with yes
and the other way to think of it is
without enough fuel in a
is there fuel this little molecule
called nad if you don't have enough nad
they are very slow at doing their job
they kind of they get detached from what
they should be doing and then they drift
off through the liquid in cell and they
don't have enough energy to to fully fix
the DNA quickly and they don't have
enough energy we think to come back to
where they came from
but if you do have all the energy and
they're in their prime still the
youthful soar tunes they can fly off and
come back mm-hmm but it's without the
fuel lien ad or you know where is
virtual is also an activator that's one
of the things we figured out in mm so
the combination of the fuel and the
activator is virtual in the NAD is a
fantastic combination we think for
maintaining that that epigenetic
Symphony as we call it right so what is
the State of the Union when it comes to
to the scientific research on sauna
therapy you know cold therapy and its
impact on nad and sirtuins and thus
aging anti aging that's a really you
just got a big smile yeah I can I can
see why you're so good at what you do
I'm just trying to follow my curiosity
here I'm trying to keep up and and I
really want to like understand this so
anyway go ahead well so the connection
is that the sirtuins are actually
waiting for more nad production and
remember that old yeast cell that the
story that I told you about those one
gene that was turned on by temperature
and by low amino acids that gene it
makes nad okay in our bodies we have the
same equivalent gene it it's it's called
an MP TNA MPT and we discovered is now
2007 that when you stress human cells in
the dish and in in in the body as well
that you turn it on so the MPT comes on
and it makes more nad for the body and
these so tunes can do a better job sewn
MPT is really interesting we most people
don't know about it or talk about it so
I'm glad you brought it up that's why
I'm so yeah we definitely didn't talk
about this last time
right so now I haven't talked about it
publicly nem PT is is the master
regulator of nad production it's the
what we call rate limiting step in
making an ad from precursors like
vitamin b3 and so we took human cells we
put them in the dish and we stress them
out so we gave them not enough sugar we
gave them too much temperature we call
heat shock them and on came this an MPT
and they made made by nad hmm so what I
think could be going on is that the
stress on the body when I'm you know 200
and whatever Fahrenheit and then jump
plunging into basically zero degree
Celsius that is making my body make more
nad essentially mimicking the effects of
exercise and hunger mm-hmm just a
different way and making my sirtuins
work optimally
and that is something that I think is
underappreciated that this one gene is
the probably the main cause of the
benefits of all of the things that we
have figured out over the last two
thousand years of being healthy and is
there an understanding of the
relationship between the hot and cold is
it that combination that makes it
effective could you just do this on or
just do the cold therapy or like how
does it you know has that been explored
not well yeah no no and I'm asked all
the time what's the best combo of diet
right exercise we've to figure that out
and then you know you you the keys of
the kingdom arrived yeah but you have
Rhonda Patrick talking about sauna and
then you have the Iceman wim HOF talking
about the cold therapy and now you have
people like Laird who are combining
these two I'm just trying to get a sense
of like what is the ultimate stress or
you know hormesis inducing protocol
that's going to activate this nad
producing signaling mechanism right so
we need to figure that out but I have a
philosophy that drives what I do and
what I talk about and that is that you
don't want to do the same thing over and
over again mix it up right cuz you you
acclimate to that right and that's no
longer it's no longer creating the
stress response exactly so I don't
exercise every day not that I could but
I don't it's a convenient excuse yeah
really true you gonna pulse it uh-huh
all right because as soon as the body
gets used to what you know I mean this
ice bath and after three minutes I'm
like what's the big deal right
you gotta you know switch it up and
that's why I think that the best thing
that we know right now is that you want
to do some some exercise then you want
to do the sauna then you do the ice bath
that's what I do and until I know more
I'm gonna keep doing that right
similarly I would imagine you know when
you look at Valter Longo and his fasting
mimicking diet and all the science
that's emerging around intermittent
fasting I mean the the benefits of that
are kind of boiled down a hormesis right
you're trying to create a stress
response that activates certain you know
pathways in your in your system that
that relate to aging or anti-aging but I
would imagine that you could you could
develop a set point with that as well
kind of acclimate to that and get used
to it and then you're no longer
experiencing that benefit do we is that
is that it does it work that same way
with the e well it's it's complicated
because the there are two experiments
that have been done one is to
consistently just give mice low-grade
food and basically mix their food with
cardboard cellulose and that works so if
my son nibbling all day on low-calorie
food that still works so you don't have
to do intermittent fasting for this to
work you never get used to not eating
yeah yeah your body will still respond
but at least we understand what's going
on and again it's this an MPT gene in
large part that's turned on when your
body doesn't have enough glucose and
insulin is being produced but also this
intermittent fasting the reason I like
it
and I you know volt has been an old
friend we used to by the way we used to
study yeast cells together yeah well we
both came from the intermittent fasting
for me is is better because it means you
can eat instead of 70 percent normal
calories you can eat 95 percent or 100
percent calories you just have to
squeeze it into a window of a few hours
to be optimal and that's just easier to
do right and in the mouse world if we do
calorie restriction which is this low
quality diet or low calorie diet of
course versus intermittent fasting they
both work
about the same that you know you can
argue about my new [ __ ] but basically
they all extend lifespan but the Meister
on intermittent fasting can eat a lot
more in their lifetime yeah and you know
if you're not eating food and enjoying
life you know it's not worth it probably
but I need to get hormesis hormesis I'm
gonna starve myself well yeah I I'm
skipping one to two meals a day and it's
changed my life I feel great and a lot
of people say it makes me feel queasy or
my stomach's burning I found I get used
to it and if you if you find that it's
too hard try cup of hot water
I think coffee is great tea and that
gets me through the morning mm-hmm
yeah I've been playing around with it
and experimenting with it for a while
and and I found that that you know it's
so much of this psychological and mental
like I'm now in a place where you know
there's plenty of days where I won't eat
until dinner and it's not because I'm
trying to provoke suffering like it's
just I'm not even really thinking about
it where you really realize realize it
and I know you posted about this on
Instagram the other day is when you fly
when you get when you get on a long
plane and I use those generally as
opportunities to to play around with
this thing because I'm not gonna eat the
food that they're serving on an airplane
and it's hard to get healthy food in
airports and the like but for the most
part most flights are you know four to
six hours unless you're going to
Australia which we're gonna talk about
it's not that big of a deal right and
then when the when the flight attendant
kind of repeatedly drops by and says
they're sure you don't want anything and
they're the look on their face they're
just like amazed that you're not eating
and you're like it's not that big of a
deal right they're saying but but you've
paid for this it's free you have to eat
it do you want some ice cream and
cookies no it'd go away the more you say
no the more they come back yeah but I I
agree with you it's a moment to really
test yourself because you're sitting
there and all you've got to think about
is the food and the person next to you
is eating right and then then you really
test your mental will and actually I use
that as a way to test myself and one of
the things I do is I think you know it's
fine to eat now
what do I want to look like feel like a
day a week from now 30 years from now
and that allows me to help my future
self yeah well you don't look a day
older than the last time we spoke which
was at least a year ago I think yes
sorry 50 51 50
no I'm still I'm still 50 but uh yeah no
gray hair I'll let you know
no yeah definitely not a gray hair on
your head yet and what maybe this is a
good place to talk a little bit about
the difference between the biological
clock and what you call horvath clock
right the [ __ ] the Horvath measure of
Aging
yeah can we talk about that yeah that's
really important it's a massive
breakthrough in the field of aging for
many many reasons one of the big things
that's held us back in studying aging is
we didn't have a real measure of what
aging was you could look at a mouse or a
human and say okay
they look younger they look old big deal
but we needed a mathematical and a a non
subjective measure and we finally had
that finally until recently all we had
was some blood tests that tell you
you're looking okay you're looking
healthy you're on the right track but
the clock changes everything because
it's a mathematical clock and actually
Horvath who's Steve Howe that's one of
my very good friends great guy he's a
mathematician by training and somebody
got their clock measured by him I'll
tell you in a minute about how the clock
works but someone said I got a really
bad result on my clock I'm biologically
10 years older are you sure the clock is
right and he said as intrude German for
me said I think Austrian actually he
said there's a greater chance that the
earth will be hit by a meteorite
tomorrow so that's how good this is and
it's not so hard of a bedside manner
though no no if it's got a great dry
sense of humor so what we've got
actually is and the beautiful thing
about it is it's not just helpful to be
able to say this is how old an animal or
a human is biologically but also it
comes back to this information theory of
aging the epigenetic information is what
I think is lost during aging
the most important thing that basically
the penis not the piano the clock is
measuring the pianist's of state of mind
right and when so what Steve's doing
with his clock he's measuring how
demented the pianist is so that that's
of course a metaphor what's actually
happening in real life is that our DNA
has chemicals on it that tell which gene
to be on and off that's basically that
the notes are for a symphony the the Ray
score but it when you're born you have a
certain pattern of these what are called
methyls these are little chemicals just
carbon and three hydrogen's that bond to
the C letter you know on DNA there's a
CT gene right so the C's get this
methylation it's called just a chemical
that sticks there and doesn't come off
unless the body takes it off it's a
permanent mark and that's what says that
gene needs to be switched off that gene
in your brain only comes on in the liver
so keep that off for the rest of your
life
and I think that that pattern that
changes over time is what drives aging
now what Steve found independently from
me is that if you can read the pattern
of those methyls it'll change over time
and if you use machine learning and say
okay this is the pattern of a 50 year
old 20 year old even a five year old you
can draw a straight line mm-hmm and then
once you've got that straight line he
can hear I can take your blood map your
methylation pattern as we call it and
place you exactly within a few percent
error of where you are on that curve or
on that straight line and then we can
say you're likely to die in July 2050 oh
wow I would imagine that gets more and
more accurate every day right as the
data set grows it is we're learning a
lot we've got now clocks for human skin
the blood in my lab we've got mouse
liver and kidney but also here's the
amazing thing we didn't know this until
just a couple of years ago that you can
take a dog's clock and use it to predict
the age of a human or a sheep or a bat
what is you know that that sounds
fanciful but what that's telling me
Steve is that there's a universal
underlying clock of aging in mammals at
least and I think it probably goes all
the way back to jellyfish we're gonna do
a jellyfish clock because jellyfish can
be immortal so we want to figure that
out how that works but what we basically
have converged on we think is that I'm
saying I think we understand what drives
aging mainly is the loss of that perfect
pattern of which genes are on and off
when we're young and that Steve has a
figured out has figured out a way it's
actually quantify that mmm so what is
your what is your age according to the
Horvath math I don't know yet and when
are you gonna die what do you mean here
you don't know no no I've been too busy
but no I've done just the the
old-fashioned blood tests and uh-huh but
I'm gonna do it I'm not avoiding it I
tell you what we are doing that I
haven't told anybody it's a little bit
of a secret but why not right now the
test costs a lot of money
mmm I think a really good deep test
would cost him at least 300 sometimes a
thousand bucks to do so it's not cheap
and he can't do it every week he can't
do it every month but we're working in
my lab when he just had a breakthrough
we think him we can bring it down to
five or ten dollars and then you could
do it at home right if you if you brave
enough there's another business for you
yeah well that that will be hopefully a
business that's one of the reasons we're
doing it but also right now it's too
expensive to measure the age of a
million people but without technology we
could do that right and then things get
interesting then we can say people who
drink this coffee that I'm holding in my
hand how do they do does their clock go
backwards or not mmm and finally we can
figure out within a short period of time
what things work for slowing or
reversing aging and there was a study
that Steve was on recently last year
that at least suggested with a small
number of people that a treatment in
humans could actually reverse the age of
those people by at least a couple of
years Wow
yeah then the data becomes unbelievably
valuable right it's it's less about what
the consumer finds out about his or her
life and more about the value of that
data set and what you can
straw plate from a lot of people are
scared to measure their age because I
don't want to know that you know even
myself I will admit I'm kind of scared
to look yeah what would happen if it
said you know here here you are the the
anti-aging longevity guy you're gonna
die in two years yeah that would not be
good for a bad day for business yeah
well you know I don't live perfectly
that's for sure
I don't every day I jump up and down in
a swimming pool like I probably should
be and I'm on planes a lot which is not
good I'm sitting down a lot I'm typing
so there's I might actually be older
they're not than I look who knows I will
I will tell everybody when I get that
data but here's the really important
point rich which is that data is
important right I'm data-driven as a
scientist but everybody with their
bodies should be cognizant of how
they're doing just ignoring aging is not
gonna make it go away or slow down so
what happens if you find out that you're
a bit older than you actually are based
on your birthday candles what does that
mean is that do you just go to bed and
get it have depression no this is
enabling what it means is that you can
actually alter the trajectory of your
life that trajectory that you're on it's
not fixed just because I say you're
gonna die the beginning of 2050 that's
if you don't change anything but you can
bend the needle and the things we're
talking about today
the hormesis effects we already know can
actually change the slope right since we
last spoke has there been any
interesting breakthroughs or new studies
or science that has kind of shifted or
or expanded your perspective on any
other things we talked about last time I
yeah a lot you know every day I before I
get out of bed I'm actually reading
scientific papers can you believe it
pretty much every day I'm excited by
something new there was something a
couple of weeks ago that came up but but
I'd been hoping to see for at least 12
years and that was to find out why does
whereas Verret role activate the sirtuin
enzyme
why is that so one idea is that we're
sensing the stress in and verse
adversity of our food but we also have
hypothesized since we first discovered
virtual and its role in aging anti-aging
is that it's probably mimicking
something that our bodies make mm-hmm
we call it the endogenous activator the
elusive endogenous activator and what
this paper showed was that the
byproducts of that at the what we call
lipolysis the breakdown of fat when you
when you're hungry produces
monounsaturated fatty acids the kind
that you can get from olive oil right
those molecules circulating in the blood
are about a thousand times more potent
than resveratrol and activating this
longevity enzyme so what does that tell
us
first of all resveratrol is pretty cool
you can mimic your body's fasting state
by by ingesting it but also it means
that we kind of been vindicated because
we got a lot of crap for his role yeah
if you google your name and resveratrol
there's a there's a lot of [ __ ] talking
coming in your direction
yeah earlier stuff from years ago well
yeah and it's been it's been a brutal
part of my career but we've always gone
back to the bench and done better
science because of those challenges and
one of the big challenges in my career
was that resveratrol we said it
activates this enzyme by actually
literally sticking to and binding to it
physically and making it more active
like a Pac Man would move faster and
then a couple of companies came out big
big pharma companies and their
scientists said literally that is bull
right and that's Bruin that happens and
everyone almost everybody except close
friends said are we gonna believe with
companies and David's wrong and that
that's a tough time in anyone's career
in my lab shrank down to about fifth of
its size and couldn't get great money
but we fought back we went back to the
bench I got out of bed eventually and I
had a student called basil Hubbard who's
now professor in Canada he didn't give
up everyone else in my lab was kind of
like oh we're screwed
let's get out of here a sinking ship he
said know what you know what I'm gonna
test this and he he worked really hard
and figured out that the experiment that
we originally did too
show that resveratrol was activating the
enzyme in the test tube was not an
artifact and it was actually real so we
published that in the journal Science in
2013 and so that the scientific ha Bob
went down mm-hmm
basically we were you know largely
accepted that we were correct but out in
the media you know no one no one cares
about correction of a scientific idea
it's all about the controversy that's
interesting and so that's still out
there in the world so anyone listening
who who knows that this was
controversial we've actually
scientifically resolved the controversy
whether it's true or not it is true but
it still left open the question is there
something in the body that we make that
activates the enzyme like resveratrol
does mm-hmm so this new study then
basically kind of you know what I infer
from that is that we should be eating
monounsaturated fats or that we should
somehow be truck be trying to trigger
this lipolysis you know situations so
that we are you know creating this
impact that we're trying to have I mean
what do we do with this information yeah
well I think the the lipolysis were
going to be doing with intermittent
fasting anyway oh it's up and down but I
think that the most exciting thing about
the paper is that they found that oleic
acid from olive oil is also a very
potent nano molar for the aficionados
activator of sirt1
so what does that mean that means that
when you eat olive oil you're actually
activating your sirtuins quite potently
because it's also just like where's
virtual mimicking this lipolysis effect
and maybe the I and the authors of that
paper have written that this could
explain why the Mediterranean diet is so
healthy mm-hmm or alternatively in in
lieu of olive oil you can get the same
result via resveratrol well yeah so one
thing that occurred to me was so I've
been taking resveratrol for over 10
years now and I'm glad I have maybe I
should have been taking a little bit of
olive oil as well but resveratrol has no
calories so I basically been drinking
olive oil for the last decade with
calories right that's a good thing what
is we talk a little bit about this last
time I think it's worth exploring a
little bit more what is the difference
between taking in resveratrol via you
know red wine versus a supplement in
terms of bioavailability and your body's
ability to kind of metabolize it yeah so
resveratrol is unfortunately a pretty
insoluble molecule now in the plant what
they the plants do is they put a sugar
on on it and it's quite soluble for the
plant but for some reason we we like to
purify it away from the sugars well not
for some reason because if you don't
it's a sticky horrible mess so we
isolate resveratrol that's free and
clear of all these other bells and
whistles that the plants like to stick
on them but what we're left with is
basically a crusty dry powder that
doesn't get absorbed by the body very
very much and even if it does it gets
basically gotten rid of by the liver so
what we had to learn early on even for
worm studies when we were showing or as
virtual extends the worms is you have to
dissolve resveratrol in some sort of
solvent so for worms we use a thing
called DMS so in humans we found in the
early 2000s that you if you mix it with
a fatty meal and that's true for mice as
well
you get about five to ten fold the
levels and so I always mix my
reservatrol with something that's got a
little bit of fat in it like a homemade
yogurt every morning and what I what
I've noticed is that the studies in
people that have not showing the
benefits other ones the way they've just
given a dry capsule to the patients or
the subjects and those that work are
those typically that are giving it with
a meal or something that the resveratrol
would dissolve in right so there is some
sense that that that definitely
increases the no question we did these
clinical trials a long time ago as we
were working our way to making a drug
and but we actually we ended up making
synthetic molecules that were a thousand
times more effective than resveratrol we
didn't know at the time we were making
the equivalent of olive oil alig acid
but i guess now we do know that those
molecules actually went into clinical
studies with with humans that's also not
very well known
and there's a the skin condition
psoriasis it worked really well they
that popped a pill of these activators
and one of these activators and the
patients did better now I'm still hoping
by the time I die I'll have one of these
medicines on the market we're not there
yet
yeah and that's actually one of the
brutal take-home messages actually is um
I don't want to complain because I've
been very lucky in my life it's it
saddens me that that in science you can
be derailed by a decade for a decade by
you know by your your naysayers
and I'm hoping to get things back on the
rails seems like so far so good well the
last time we spoke you know this book
has not come out yet now it's been out
you've been doing the you did the book
tour thing and you know I kind of
canvassed some of the press around that
and it's interesting because it's my
sense is that on the one hand kind of in
popular culture you're being feted and
and celebrated for this book and your
work breakthroughs you know this bold
you know taking this very bold position
that that aging is reversible that we're
on the precipice of new science and
breakthroughs that are gonna
revolutionize how humans live their
lives and and think about their lives
and on the other hand you know some
pushback from the conventional
scientific community and some grumbling
amongst you know the old guard saying
not so fast you know what I mean
thank you like fast yeah you're you
you've got your your foot on the
accelerator and and they seem to be
saying you know slow down you're you're
you're kind of out over your skis here
yeah that's true but that's you know so
be it
we have a certain amount of time on this
planet and I'm going as fast as I can
the other thing that most scientists
don't realize is sometimes it takes us a
decade to publish our work so we know I
know a lot more about what we're working
on than other people and when they say
to me Oh David or say behind my back
David's out over his skis they they only
think that I know what's published but
we've got all these other stuff so when
we were challenged by these companies
even though it was sad I had
a whole body of data from my lab that
said uh I'm not don't be so sure of
yourself but yeah it's tough as a
scientist
especially one at a conservative
university like Harvard you know I often
get my knuckles right because I'm out
there right but but I do it not because
I'm seeking fame or anything I'm pretty
shy guy but I do want to see
technologies adopted within our lifetime
you know it's fine future generations
will do well but I really do think that
it would be a real shame if our
generation was the last to live a normal
lifespan
you would think that Harvard would
celebrate this I mean don't they want
people that are sort of breaking
paradigms and pushing the envelope I
mean what is the purpose of a lab if not
to test the limits of our of our
understanding and the kind of you know
dream boldly yeah well so in Havas
defense what what gets them riled up is
when I get misinterpreted by mainstream
media so I rarely now talk to that never
happens yeah it's tough as a scientist
because you you you say here are the
facts here the facts and the headlines
out for me typically is Harvard
scientist says we're all gonna live 250
right which I'd never have said but then
the University says David what the heck
are you saying it's like so you know
it's easier for me to not now talk to
sensationalist media and I've now I'm
much more comfortable doing this kind of
thing where I can talk directly to the
public right and I appreciate your not
getting misquoted yeah and and and how's
the lab doing like how and how are the
colleagues like in the wake of the books
success New York Times bestseller like
you know books everywhere everywhere you
look I see it you know how are they kind
of you know acting towards you now good
yeah I've had no backlash about the book
which surprised me because I've it's a
bold thing to say you know we figured
this out it upsets a lot of people right
but as far as I know they're not upset
in fact I've had a lot of praise from
colleagues it's cool the book is I mean
congratulations I think it's a it's I
really think that
it is a paradigm breaking master work
and what's what's really interesting and
unique about it and and I suspect
unsuspected for somebody's gonna pick
this up is that is that it's not just
this hardcore scientific tome it's sort
of you weave in a little mem memoir
aspect to it you tell these stories
there are incredible illustrations
throughout I know you want like an award
for the illustrations or the artist did
and you tell these amazing stories and
you have these kind of poetic
you know chapter titles so it's a
different experience than then I was
expecting looking into it like it's it's
it's kind of general john rebending in
that regard well thanks I appreciate it
you know anyone who knows me I'm not not
really a scientist I'm doing science and
because I have a goal in life I in high
school I was an artist and some of the
illustrations at the back of the book I
drew myself moon for headshots so I'm an
artist masquerading as a scientist but I
think they go well together actually I'm
I think in terms of shapes and things
moving around I'm not so much a
mathematician mathematician but that
that's why the book ended up being like
that also have to give a big shout-out
to my co-author Matt LaPlante who took a
whole bunch of crazy ideas that I had
and synthesized them and wove them into
this narrative including some history
which I really believe that the best way
to predict the future is to look back
over the last 200 years to see where
we're going especially also when you
look at society and a lot of things are
said about the work that we're doing oh
we're all gonna run out of jobs we're
gonna have not enough food or we can do
with all these people of population if
you look back at history we've always
been worried about that right and there
are solutions I mean it's not perfect we
can't have unlimited number of people on
the planet but that's why I wove history
in there because you forget that if
people have gone through these kinds of
things before and come out the other
side much better I don't think you'd
want to go back to the 1840s with
cholera rampant now but we have our own
particular set of problems now and I do
want to explore the kind of ethical and
philosophical implications of your work
and I think a good kind of inroad into
that is to start with Australia right
your Australian last time you were on
the show you
told these amazing stories about your
grandmother Vera wearing a bikini on
Bondi Beach for the first time and just
being this like you know I don't know
like I just wish I had someone like her
in my life she just sounded amazing and
I can see how you know her influence on
you has catalyzed this path that you've
been on but I spent I just spent a month
in Australia I was there for all of
December I think you were probably there
for part of that as well right yeah I
think we probably overlapped yeah and
and it was it was quite something being
in in Sydney and amidst these fires and
it's I know it's even worse right now in
terms of air quality around that city
but it was relatively dystopian on days
people walking around with masks on you
really you know couldn't breathe the air
the sky was orange the entire you know
Khosla I mean it's just the the the the
sheer scope of what's happening there
right now is hard to imagine I mean I
saw a new story this morning that said
the smoke from the fires has actually
circumnavigated the entire globe and is
now back to Australia after going all
the way around the planet yeah yeah it
definitely feels like Armageddon when
you're there and even I'm live in Boston
of course and a few days ago it was 70
degrees and you know you walk out there
you go this is this is craziness you
know I grew up in Sydney right on the
bush as I described in the book I almost
had my house burned down actually last
week my brother's family lost a house it
was all burnt down and there's nothing
left excepting a bit of steel on the
ground everything else just toasted it
it really brings home the fact that we
are living in in dangerous times and you
can deny it you can deny that the world
isn't changing and we've lived through
these times before but let's just face
it let's use Occam's razor the simplest
explanation is that the world is [ __ ]
up and we are cooked the cause of it
it's not that hard to admit unless
you've got some other agenda and
Australia is a if you've never been to
the Australian bush you got to realize
this isn't like a forest with soil
this is tinder this is the kind of
leaves that if you put it in a fire they
explode there full of oils eucalyptus
oil mainly and it's not hard to start a
fire you better than you know throw
cigarette out or whatever once it's
going this is basically a fire that you
cannot put out because it's it's not
just going from leaf to leaf it's going
from tree to tree across the top it's
creating its own weather patterns there
was a couple of firemen were killed
because the truck was caught in a
tornado and blown on top of them right
that's arm again kind of stuff and you
go there and there's just this
I think the Australians are in shock
when I was a kid my house almost burnt
down I know what it's like to feel that
your house has been burned down the
problem that I see now is that you know
this is this is not a one-off fires in
Australia normally starting around
February and you know where we were in
December or January and this could be
the new normal in California right now
it's it's fires all year round pretty
much yeah and this fire in Australia has
been going on for like four months at
this point
right right right and the safe are
similar but it's a lot of different
fires or it sort of meeting up with each
other etc yeah yeah it's it's a scary
world and we have to do something and so
what
so most people look at me and like Oh
David you you study mice what would you
know about climate change I have a
conscience and I think about the impact
of my research all the time and what
I've written about is that we need to
mobilize resources on the planet
billions if not trillions of dollars to
tackle this as well as other problems we
have like energy resources consumption
you got to take money from somewhere to
solve these problems if they don't solve
themselves we can take it from the
military you could there's opposition to
that you could take it from education
you don't need to do that what about
health care right now we waste billions
of dollars taking care of the elderly
who don't need to be old if if we're
right and we do the kind of things that
we talked about today as well as
advances we could have a world by the
time we're elderly where people in their
80s are just starting a new career like
my dad did that's a world where you a
glow bit word save trillions of dollars
okay so now it's easy to say you save
trillion dollars but that's money that
can be poured into solving these
problems I
to think about old London a lot because
old London in 1840 the cholera thing
that I mentioned people in the 1840s
they weren't solving the world's
problems because they were too busy
trying to figure out why everyone's
dying in a world where people are not
dying and you're not taking care of them
then you've got the resources to solve
these problems mm-hmm and I don't know
any other way besides stopping the
military spending of getting a few
trillion dollars to spend yeah I mean
the silver lining in what's happening in
Australia is the opportunity that it
will catalyze political will right and
one of the things that was interesting
when I was there is I didn't fully have
have a sense of just how conservative
the government is and you know
everything that's going on with the PM
and he goes to Hawaii in the middle of
all this on vacation and you know the
the impact of the coal industry on kind
of you know the political perspective on
what to do or not to do is all very
interesting right so you're somebody who
is incredibly optimistic about about
human ingenuity and you know excited
about the potential of our species to
innovate our way out of any problem that
we find ourselves in and I can see that
perspective and to some extent I can
agree with that but I think the limiters
are are really you know the the
government's and the politicians who are
tied up in old systems that are holding
us back and basically exacerbating the
problems we're trying to solve
yeah no doubt no doubt and just to hit
the exclamation point old London when
they figured out that it was actually
cholera from the water well what snow
did was he removed the handle of the
pump and cholera went away but talk
about politicians what's not really
known is that the politicians were under
pressure because people didn't want to
admit that the fecal-oral route of
infection was true they thought it was
you in the air so they actually the
politicians put the pump handle back on
and for another couple of years there
were still cholera plagues in London so
you know you talk about politicians
screwing things up I absolutely agree
that if we can mobilize human engineer
we can solve anything but we do a very
bad job of that I think where we are
here in California is a hot spot for
innovation but most of the world doesn't
really innovate yeah when we look at the
state of healthcare in the United States
I mean it's just it's it's horrific
compared to where it could be in terms
of what we could be doing for people and
it's such a Byzantine mess I don't see
our way through it or out of it without
some really significant changes at the
highest level well I agree with you and
that's one of the things that we're
doing in the aging field is to talk to
politicians as well as the FDA to
convince them that aging is something
that is important right now if you talk
to most doctors even geriatricians who
treat older people aging is just the way
it goes we've got to deal with it it's
natural well you know when have we
humans put up with what's natural if we
didn't want to everything else we we
work on Aging is one of these things
let's all live with it but in at the
political level I and my colleagues have
talked to them it's slow you can't
change the course the Titanic too
quickly but we do see things bending and
the FDA is actually agreed that if we do
certain clinical trials for instance
with metformin the diabetes drug that we
think might slow aging if we can hit
certain end points and show things are
actually working they are well prepared
to consider calling aging a treatable
condition if not a disease that's right
that we can prescribe medicines for
right yeah I mean the kind of underlying
theme in the book and in your work is
this idea that there is no biological
law that we need to age like we just
sort of accept that as a truism but in
fact you know that's that doesn't
necessarily hold water no no no nobody
has any reason to say that that we have
this clock that that cannot be changed
in fact what we've learned going back to
the horvath clock is that about 80% of
our lifestyle
80% of our health in old age is due to a
lifestyle how we live right and only 20%
is genetic and actually that that's done
by studying twins who you know some
smokes I'm done
I live different all this stuff your
jeans are not your destiny that's the
good news
so that what that means is it's up to
you and if you want to be frail or to be
honest dead at 80 go for it we know how
to do that do everything that the
marketing people want you to do eat the
cake sit on your fat ass and watch
movies that'll get you there pretty
quickly
yeah but fortunately you know in part
thanks to new media like this we can
actually all talk about what we think of
their ways to extend lifespan and and
and not be frail in old age like my
father I talk about him a lot I'm very
proud of him as a beacon of hope at 80
he's still running around like he's 25
he's got no aches or pains very sharp
minded using all sorts of high-tech
lifting more weights than I can actually
and our trainer who's currently training
the two of us together
he says you know what I think my dad was
dead lifting what was it uh something
like 180 pounds something a lot and he
said the last 80 year old that I trained
was was learning how to get out of a
chair right yeah you uh you posted
something on Instagram he's like you
know in the in the squat machine or
whatever like just killing it at 80 the
guys in his second career he's had this
kind of you know resurgence and vitality
as a result of finding new purpose and
meaning and he's also somebody who's
been on your kind of protocol for a
while at this point and to see him in
the gym at 80 like crushing it it's it's
very inspiring well I think most of us
can achieve that in life know there will
be unlucky people that of course
diseases dual heroes but most of us are
wasting our lives because we're
basically not not you but most people
don't think about their longevity they
dif they think oh when I'm old I'll deal
with that when it kinds but now in early
and midlife is the time to invest
because it'll pay off dividends later in
life mm-hmm we've done such a good job
with medicine and pharma and increasing
I mean you would probably disagree but
an increasing lifespan but not so good
in terms of increasing health span right
like we now
have to dodge all these bullets of
modern life just to basically you know
counteract that genetic marker to extend
our vitality right through the processed
foods and the kind of you know luxury
imperative that our culture you know
reaffirms and enforces like all of these
things we have to kind of opt out of the
you know dominant paradigm in order to
kind of thrive later in life
yeah well the dominant paradigm that's
that's existed now for about 300 years
is that doctors treat diseases they
don't treat lifestyle typically there
are exceptions but mostly the doctors
around where I work at these great
hospitals you they only see patients
after they get sick and so the the the
aging process is already pretty advanced
at that point and aging is let's not be
be silly about it
aging is what's driving cancer heart
disease Alzheimer's it's the main cause
of disease and disability on this planet
it's not I mean do these diseases are
real but they're the endpoint of this
process that we're working on but most
doctors don't think about aging they
don't think about what got people to the
cliff in the first place and I call it
whack-a-mole medicine which is and this
is all great I'm not criticizing my
colleagues we are we do need medicines
we need to treat diseases but it's a
little too late for a lot of people and
this whack-a-mole medicine leads to the
the paradigm of coming with a disease
we'll treat it hopefully fix it kick you
out the door
wait till you get sick again come back
and repeat until failure mm-hmm let's
talk a little bit about the ethics of
your work so we were talking about
Australia you know if we just look at
what's happening there as as a symbol of
you know climate change in action and I
kind of you know degraded planet Earth
in a certain trajectory that we're on
and have been on for some time as
somebody who you know by your own words
said you know I'm concerned about the
climate just like everybody else you
have this mission to extend lifespan
which inevitably is going to lead to
population growth which is an exact
servant to the climate change problem
that we're trying to solve so let's kind
of dig in to this and the implications
of like let's say you're successful and
your colleagues are successful and we
get to a place where people can live to
be 150 175 people are I would I would
imagine more likely to have more kids
there's more people on the planet
suddenly we have to sustain a greater
population and deal with these other
problems that we so far today too
haven't been so good at dealing with so
everything you said was right except one
thing hmm
the healthier people are the less kids
they have later in life so we can now
extend the healthy period of life and we
think based on some animal studies
extend fertility so women in the future
will be able to have kids much later in
life and have fewer the fewer of them
but let's look at the planet we do have
any show on the planet of course we've
been going on exponential growth for the
last couple hundred years for our
species but it's it's not the doomsday
that we thought it was in the 1970s
Malthus and the erlik's used to panic
make all of us panic because they said
don't slow population growth well about
you're running out of resources if you
extrapolate this curve vertically of
course we're all gonna starve to death
in the next thirty years actually they
thought by now we'd all be starving to
be fair but what's happening is that
what they didn't realize would happen I
think most of us didn't predict is that
as populations across the globe become
healthier they become wealthier when
they're wealthier they become healthier
and then you'd Li you have women who
become educated mm-hmm and women don't
want to have 15 kids they don't want to
always be pregnant when you give them
the choice they have you noticed a few
and where we're seeing is particularly
in Africa the rates of population growth
are dramatically declining I was just in
Uganda and late last year and I was
talking to the locals and I said you
know tell me how your family all my
grandparents 15 kids or 13 kids I
exaggerate I have five brothers and
sisters what about you oh we only want
to have two
want to give them an education that's
happening across the planet so well you
know I'm drawing these curves anyone
who's listening can't see this but
basically we're tapering off this
exponential growth we're going to max
out according to the United Nations
World Health Organization at about 11
billion now that that's still a lot of
people of course max out on the
resources no no the number of people on
the planet so it's already tapering off
and we're gonna hit a sustainable level
and actually start to decline in
population based on projections why
wouldn't we just continue to populate
until we blow through that ceiling well
because it let's look at um even in the
u.s. actually population is going down
and is barely a replacement level in
Western Europe its declining couples on
average are having less than two kids
and as plenty of people who choose not
to have kids yeah I mean this is one of
Paul Hawkens big things when he in his
book draw down one of the most powerful
tools in the war against climate change
or the you know the the battle to to
solve this problem is educating girls
the more we can educate girls in the
developing world they're less likely to
you know have as many kids right exactly
exactly so we're gonna help build some
schools over in Kenya that if anyone who
can see this risk brand this reminds me
everyday first of all how lucky I am
with my family here in the US but also
that there are people on the other side
of the planet that need our help
but you're right being a woman in in the
these countries is the worst they're if
they don't have a well they have to walk
you know thanks for - Justin Rainey's
helping with the wells those things
giving them water giving them education
that's part of the solution to the
problem of overpopulation and it doesn't
initially make sense but what you just
said rich is the most important thing
give women the choice to decide how many
kids they have right conversely as a
thought experiment let's say you could
live 200 years and and a you know a
female's ability to reproduce extends
way later into life you can have these
you know now it's sort of like you
mature you have kids and then you kind
of you know gray into your older years
but
you could get like two cracks at this
right like you could have kids and they
grow up and you get older and then you
get a new career and you know then you
could just say hey let's do this again
Yeah right you I'm sure there'll be
people and we know people like that I
won't name names but I know a 98 year
old who has a kid who's in their 70s and
also in their twenties
anyway I'm proud of him he why I'm
mentioning his name Martin Norman Lear
he's fantastic okay norms of one of
those guys but but most people don't do
that yeah but but but if what I'm saying
is when you're not just extending the
number of years of your run you're
extending your vitality into those years
right so if you if you remain vital
later in life like the idea of having a
child at age 70 if you're operating the
way you were when you were 40 seems like
not such a bad idea thank you for saying
that because this isn't about science
fiction living 170 and having you know a
third of the world in wheelchairs what
we're talking about is real life how
much time do you want to spend with your
parents before they get sick how or do
you want them to spend another you know
decade in a nursing home before they die
this is really personal but it also
we've got to throw away our
preconceptions of what being old is
right we talk about lead Hamilton in his
50s he's basically got the body and the
looks of someone much much much younger
being 50 is not old anymore suddenly 60
even 80 like my father that's not old
anymore if you take care of yourself you
extrapolate that into the future
there'll be a day when being a hundred
isn't old you know they'll still be
people who don't take care of themselves
and be sick at 60 that'll always happen
but on average people will continue to
live longer we've been on this
trajectory of living healthier and being
more youthful in our old age for the
last few hundred years and a child born
today if we stay on that trajectory here
in the u.s. can expect not just hope but
expect to live 104 okay that means that
they'll still be healthy 80 and 90 mm
which is great it's all about keeping
people healthier for the longest period
and then dying relatively quickly
yeah when I was you know ten years old
if there was a Laird Hamilton doing what
he was doing it would just be it would
it would have blown people's minds right
I mean not that he doesn't blow people's
minds now but that would just be the the
craziest thing you'd ever heard of
exactly so we live in a wonderful world
where people can learn about things that
typically they never read about or maybe
they'd have to wait 20 years right my
research I'm talking about it as it
happens pretty much it's it's a crazy
world we live in but it's wonderful and
also young people now have access to
information you go back to when we were
kids how did we get information well
there was the local library which was
books that were basically old and musty
or you could go to a World Book
Encyclopedia or is Encyclopedia
Britannica and look up you know a
paragraph of something and this was all
data and information that was old and
not cutting-edge today you can learn
about stuff that's happening and change
your life based on things that we only
dreamed about his kids right from a
philosophical perspective and like kind
of playing playing on this thought
experiment like let's say you could live
200 300 years how does that impact the
psychology of a young person's mind in
terms of how they make decisions about
their career path or what they want
their life to look like and we did talk
a little bit about this last time but I
I'm interested in in how that impacts
like risk assessment right like if
you're if you're like hey man I'm I'm 18
and I'm gonna live to 300 you know
barring me getting hit by a bus like you
know I have a lot of life to live so am
I really gonna go skydiving because then
the risk of that seems so much more
severe than it would if you're looking
at well I'm gonna only lift it you know
life short and I'm gonna die at 80
anyway like I'm gonna roll the dice and
take these risks and then how does that
play out on a macro level in terms of
what culture and society looks like yeah
well we're already on that path I don't
think people in the 1840s and 50s were
worried about bicycle helmets if they
had bicycles
you know what I mean that the long
we live healthy we are the more
protective we are of our bodies and our
children and that'll continue right now
that we're seeing a rubber banding with
that with like Jonathan height and what
he's doing in terms of like you know we
need to rewilding want them go outside
without a helmet on it's lost her in the
street it's extreme I just got back from
Shanghai where there are cameras that
that shame you on Billboard's if you
cross the street
when the lights are really the red yeah
and it's and it's got a shame you it
like a photo of your face yeah right on
the street you can see the lady that
crossed the street this morning that uh
disobeyed the rules and she apparently
like as demerit points on her social
sister social score oh that's just like
that's black mirror stuff right there
yeah scary stuff hopefully this world
that we live in won't be like that
anytime soon but yeah that the the risks
will you don't want to take massive risk
but you know what I think that we're
we're exaggerating maybe if we live for
a million years we're gonna be a little
bit more cautious crossing the street
but I think that if we live to 150 say
there were those of us who like taking
risks anyway I don't think somebody says
I'm gonna wait till I'm 90 to jump out
of an aeroplane
Doreen you're 20 right so it's there are
risk takers and most of us will still
take risks in life you know people
actually funny funny side is people
think that I'm scared to die because I'm
working on Aging but anyone who see me
drive my car knows that that's not true
I'm a big risk-taker ocean Allah on the
road I'm not well not anymore I'm now
bit sedated but oh I shouldn't say
sedated but I'm more calm about my
driving but I do drive a fast car I
Drive it a Tesla for that but but I do
like I do like the feeling of risk and
it's the reason that I'm in this career
in the first place cuz I took a lot of
risks when I was young to get here point
being you know maybe I'll live to 100
maybe 150 I don't know maybe I'll die
tomorrow you know I don't care I like
doing things that are novel I like doing
things that are risky and I think that a
lot of us will still do that no matter
how long we're gonna live
but I think the trend in in the world is
that the longer we live
the more scared we become of danger
right fireworks are we gonna worry about
fireworks yeah that kind of thing but
I'm not so worried I think that these
are small prices to pay for a world that
is different from today as we are from
1840 London yeah I think in tandem with
trying to elongate life's lifespan and
health span you know we also have to
solve these other kind of you know
cultural dilemmas that we find ourselves
in that are contributing to mental
decline and emotional decline the
disconnection the you know addiction to
technology the you know lack of purpose
that underscores most people's lives and
we talked about this last time to like
how does the how does like the work of
Gambian or in the Blue Zones kind of
intersect with your own work you know
ultimately what's the point in living so
long if you know our value system is is
you know not in alignment with you know
what's required to be fulfilled and to
be happy and to have you know purpose
for living that long yeah a hundred
percent so there's the there's the world
of molecules and genes that that I do
for my day job but I'm also very
passionate about finding mission and
purpose and doing the best you can in
life because that that's also what I
what drives me and so I think you're
right that if if you're someone who's
prone to depression giving up giving up
hope you've got to get out of that
you've got to find what excites you what
drives you I teach a lot of students at
Harvard and there are some students who
were very smart you know some of the
best brightest in the world but they're
there I'm not sure I can do that and you
know whining around I'm a compass
lapping around find a goal go for it
this is your opportunity and don't come
to me with an experiment that'll advance
science by one step come to me with with
an experiment or a question that'll
advance us 20 years into the future now
that's not easy right that's the hardest
part of
the rest is just manipulating chemicals
it's finding something that you want to
go for and change the world and that's
that's what I think has been if I have a
secret to success besides a lot of luck
and hard work it's at age four having a
goal and going for it yeah it is
interesting that that it dates all the
way back you know your whole life has
been infused with this you know this
drive this passion to you know solve
this problem or you know yeah well no
advance humanity in this way well you
know makes a good story and of course
we're looking back on it it looks pretty
easy but there were there's still are
plenty of times where I wonder you know
do I really have to get out of bed today
this is tough you know ups and downs and
I say that because anyone who who
experiences this and has adversity they
have to know that that's part of the
process you don't grow you don't learn
you don't succeed unless you go through
that and it never ends right I'm not
riding high I still have massive ups and
downs and obstacles even at my age but
I've learned actually that if you have a
goal that's what gets you through it so
when it's all said and done like what is
the what is the legacy that you're
working to leave behind like what when
you when when when you're complete what
does it look like ideally uh well of
course that's never gonna happen
but you hold this great vision so what
is that vision well I would love to have
a time machine to go a few hundred years
into the future and if I see a future
where people are able to do multiple
careers with you we're talking about
career arcs I mean what about a world
where if you know not everyone can can
have their dream job initially I would
love a world where people can live 250
expect to be still playing tennis 120 I
think it's doable there's no reason why
we can't do that with our ingenuity what
that gives you is the time to have
multiple careers multiple lives multiple
partners if you want although you may
find the right one in the beginning
but but this is gives you you know let's
let's go back in time a little bit in
1840 okay that person who's born in 1840
was not expecting to have first of all a
great time at age forty or fifty
basically you're worn out by then they
don't expect to have multiple careers
they didn't have the opportunity anyway
so if you extrapolate from there to now
and into the future just as much what
you have a world is where even if you
you're dealt the wrong cards the
beginning of life you have multiple
chances to correct that there are some
risks to take of course and you do need
some support you know I'm not running
for president I couldn't I was born in
the wrong country but what I would love
to have is what I call a skilled medical
which is well it's another chance it's
if you're busting rocks or whatever it's
that you hate two years off retrain get
another chance and if you have a long
life that's 150 years long you can do
you know one career could last twenty
thirty years become the best you can be
at that and then switch mm-hmm and that
that's a life that would be well lived
with it yeah I think it would it would
give people the patience that I think we
lack right now like every we're in such
a hurry from the moment were born you
know it's a it's a Habitrail of
achievement and measuring ourselves
against others and you know from the
moment you enter junior high school and
then it's grades in high school and it's
getting into cut like you're it's this
race right and the brain and the
emotional body isn't mature enough to
really process that to make the best
decisions how are you supposed to know I
mean you knew what you wanted to do at a
very young age most people don't right
but they're kind of you know corralled
into a certain path and on a trajectory
that for a lot of people they don't it's
like a waking dream that they don't kind
of come to out of until they're forty
and think why am I even in this position
but if we could slow things down and say
hey you're gonna live to 150 no big rush
here like take your time go on a kibbutz
you know maybe there's a national you
know sort of period of time
your your you know of service or you do
some kind of Teach for America like
programs like that that allow people
that mature and develop the
self-awareness and a sense of the world
so that they can make that decision
about how they can best contribute and
find meaning and purpose in their lives
rather than being in such a rush yeah I
couldn't have said it better you take
someone like my father who at 70 thought
he had a few good years left he'd be
getting dementia by this point he wasn't
looking forward to the future
late 70s is still perfectly fit what am
I gonna do with my life he started a new
career right and so instead of being you
know late part of your life what's my
legacy we can turn that into why don't I
just begin a new one and you know I'm
now 50 you know what it's like normally
we should be if anything was right if we
look at our parents and their
grandparents their parents 50 is the
time when you like ah I'm almost done
wind down write it but that's not how
the world is these days and in the
future will be even better we're at 50
like I'm just getting good at this
I just understand how the world works
although we you never fully get it I I
don't feel any different than I did when
I was 30 I'm have a bit more wisdom of
course but everything else is the same
physically mentally and hopefully a
greater appreciation for the wisdom of
the elderly rather than just warehousing
them in nursing homes and and trying to
put them out of our line of sight and
you know dismiss them which is the
tragic situation that we're in now yeah
it is that I the older you get actually
the more you appreciate these folks what
I want is a world where people in their
80s and 90s are not just appreciative
but actually utilized if they're healthy
they can be advising or running
companies or motivating the youth right
that's the world that I want because it
once you're in a wheelchair or in a
nursing home then you're done for
and of course young people are not gonna
want to spend their time listening to
you know who have dementia but in a
world where you can have a mentor who's
seen 90 years of really interesting
stuff how cool is that
the flip side of that is and we touched
on this last time is the hundred and
twenty year old who
still on the Supreme Court and lacks the
sort of plasticity the kind of adapt to
you know modern times who's stuck in an
era that is that is bygone and thus is
despite their wisdom and experience of
the ages isn't in lockstep with what's
actually happening right I mean that
seems to be a potential downside but
it's no perfect thing it's not perfect
right they'll still be people who who
are in positions when they're too old to
deal with right but now it's like
finally but you know these people are
we're getting rid of all these people so
we can get fresh blood in here a new
perspective I don't agree with that at
all I think that we should treasure
those folks that have the wisdom and
experience mmm because what history is
really the way to predict the future and
and they've seen it all right that
someone like a Warren Buffett I mean I
would love to keep them around for a lot
longer because someone like that it does
a lot of great things but you know yeah
Bill Gates same there are people you
want to keep around maybe there are a
few that we don't but these are the
prices to pay for a world where the
majority of us can expect to be playing
tennis on our 80th birthday right as a
result of doing this book tour I would
imagine you've probably met some pretty
interesting people I would imagine
there's some pretty cool people reaching
out to you yeah yeah you're gonna be
cagey about this right well yeah yeah I
mean it's it's you know look we all you
know we all we all want to extend our
lifespan and this book has been very
successful and you've been out talking
about it so I would imagine that that's
created some interesting encounters for
you yeah well I that's part of the the
joy that I have every day is I've
learned that people are really
interesting yeah as a teenager I didn't
go to medicine because I thought humans
were the evil on the planet I've kind of
switched it around and realized that you
can learn a lot just by listening I'm
talking today but usually I'm quite
quite quiet
I don't name-drop but but I've I've met
a lot of my idols in business in
Hollywood a lot of billionaires I
probably met a quarter of the right
billionaires at this point us but there
I
learning a little pasta Leone right yeah
well you know I am a spokesperson for
this field but I should say that there
are hundreds of scientists like me
working away every day to help solve
this problem mm-hmm of course the one
thing that everyone wants to know and
wants to talk to you about is okay
you're the guy who's steeped in this but
like what do you actually do and what's
interesting you know in hearing other
interviews with you and the last time we
spoke etc and in the book is that you're
very quick to say and very certain to
say look I'm not I'm not a medical
doctor and I'm not going to you know
give you a prescription for your life
and I'm not going to give you advice
about you know certain protocols and
it's not until you get to the conclusion
of the book where you actually say
actually here but I will tell you a few
things about what I do and it's
literally like a page in the entire book
right so I'm interested in why you
because I would imagine in most
interviews that this question gets asked
right this is what people we're like
what do you do like you're the one who
knows more about this than almost
anybody so tell me what your habits are
right well I didn't do it intentionally
but as it's worked out worked out is
that those who make it to the end of the
book get the reward right ok there it is
that's not why it's actually more that
I'm you know an unusual position right
I'm a Harvard professor I'm supposed to
be world leading scientists and
scientists are like monks monks don't go
around telling people that well actually
they do but scientists shouldn't go
around telling people how to live their
lives I'm I'm part of this monastic
group of people that are should only say
something if it's factual right and I
try my best to do that the supplements
that that I admit that I take and that's
rare for a scientist to admit that stuff
even though probably about half my
colleagues are doing something I'm out
on a limb now anyone who wants to jump
to the page that rich talked about right
page 3 page 4 eo4
yeah oh do you yeah it's so funny but
but I've realized that
there's a lot of demand for knowledge
about this and so what I've done is I've
got a newsletter and so I'm updating
people people can subscribe if they'd
like it's a life span book don't go on
and so I'm adding to those pages now
it's not just one page to be fair that
the whole of part two is about what you
can do in terms of fasting and exercise
and why it works where you just kind of
break it down and hear other things well
this is that's a cheat sheet yeah
towards the end but yeah I can't run
around saying take this supplement or
that brand is good I will first of all I
lose my credibility I've got to be
objective also I don't spend my time
testing products that's not what I do
I'm a molecular biologist geneticist but
I am willing to go out on a limb and say
what I do and what works and how I think
you should not sure but can adapt your
life the other thing that I hope
everybody realizes is that what I do is
a guide it's not proven to work but I've
got the reason the book is full of
references is if somebody wants to do a
deep dive into a subject whether it's
fasting or the cold or sauna bathing or
supplements there's a lot of other
scientific work that they can delve into
as well yeah the notes I mean the notes
go on for however many pay 360 yes like
50 pages of notes at the end right so
you know I'm trained as a scientist and
everything in that book was fact checked
to the nth degree and with references
and that's why when you read my book
versus maybe some others that are that
are not written by scientists you can
bet that what you're reading is factual
as far as we know well let's talk about
what it is that you do like let's in
your estimation like what are the most
important things that and and again you
can preface this whatever with whatever
caveat you want but like what do you
think are the most important things that
people should be doing or looking after
on a daily basis to kind of you know
take out an insurance policy against
aging given the current state of
knowledge and understanding that's well
put okay now I feel free to speak
because I don't endorse and I don't
recommend
I think the most important thing for
anybody to live healthier for longer it
goes just one thing I could say it would
be eat less often don't eat three meals
a day I literally think that that people
who recommend three meals plus snacks
trying to keep your glucose levels
always at a pretty high level are doing
the world a disservice and I'm gonna go
out on a limb to say that a lot of
nutritionists would disagree with me but
I've been doing this for thirty years
I've seen what happens to people and
animals when you restrict their food and
it it's all good I mean you don't want
malnutrition or starvation of course but
putting the body in a state of want
every day um for as long as you can do
it I do it you know like I said
hopefully until late afternoon dinner
that's the easiest and best thing you
can do mm-hmm other things are at the
high-intensity interval training or
jumping up and down with weights in a
swimming pool
almost drowning that's pretty good right
you're going back tomorrow right yeah
well I will do it again actually I'm now
I'm actually think I know not to go too
far into the deep end but but honestly
we now know we all have the the power
with the scientific basis to actually
live at least 15 years longer mm-hmm
okay so there are actually and I talked
about this I think on Twitter recently
that there are there are five things
that are pretty obvious and easy to do
that'll give you 15 years and that's
just off the top of my head things like
you know exercise the fasting don't eat
too much eat the right foods try to be
plant-based get sleep have social
network that gives you 15 years that's
amazing that's not even going it delving
deep into my book which takes it to
another level of what the best exercise
and supplements probably are so that's
the good news
I do list a lot of things we could we
could talk for hours about what I do
page three and four you'll see more I'm
conscious that we have a microbiome that
is that needs to be healthy so I make my
own special yogurt mmm which I mix my
resveratrol in I think I'll release the
recipe
of that pretty soon to the in the
newsletter if anyone would like to make
it so that these are the things on the
sorry to interject but on the you sure
sort of said you know eating eating
plant-based predominantly plant-based I
mean a lot of that is is informed by the
relationship between excessive protein
intake and that that impact on Aging
correct
well it's but from yours from your
perspective in the work that you're
doing so the so the plant-based food I
think a little bit of meats find
especially if you work out you're trying
to bilk up bulk up some muscle but I
think that what we've learned is by
studying the Sardinians and Okinawans is
that those diets are the best for humans
and they are mostly plant-based with a
little bit of meat like fish so why does
that work okay why do we think that
works the two reasons one is that you
don't want to overload on some types of
propel amino acids which you'll find in
me leucine isoleucine valine these are
turn off our body's defenses through a
pathway called mTOR will probably be a
Nobel Prize awarded for that stuff by
the way it's big deal mTOR but if you're
always eating a lot of protein in terms
of meat then you'll you'll never really
optimize your body's defenses so I try
to eat plant-based foods but there's
another thing that that most people miss
which is the Xena or hermetic molecules
from plants you get those you don't get
those from meat as much so what do you
make of a carnivore diet yeah I'm on
this on the other side yeah I it is an
interesting phenomenon good long just
like sort of culturally to go how did
this suddenly happen and there's a
cohort of people who are all about just
that's all they eat right this hasn't
been going on for very long this story
very much has yet to be fully told but
you know if somebody's listening to this
and perhaps was flirting with the idea
of that I mean you know what would be
your response to that person alright
well so I'm a scientist so let's talk
some science briefly the what what you
do when you activate this mTOR pathway
is you're telling your cells in your
body that times are good you've just
caught a mammoth okay basically and now
is the time to build your body and
actually fix things heal things and grow
and it turns out that there are two
things your body can do there's grow and
then there's on the other hand the other
side of the balance is to protect growth
protect growth protect and if you're
always in this growth mode by telling
your body now is the time you got umino
assets grow that's great when you're
young and middle-aged you'll bulk up
right you'll feel good you'll actually
burn energy more you'll lose bit of fat
but long-term you're gonna sacrifice
your longevity in my view because you're
not turning on your body's defenses
which typically are turned on when your
body senses that there's adversities a
need yeah so being hungry and eating
plants aren't gonna be telling your body
times and not as good we've run out of
mammoth meat let's hunker down but you
could soar on around we're on our own so
we're gonna have to you know do the
heavy lifting here it's it's basically
catalyzing these systems these
biological systems to protect the body
right yeah and and in turn promote
longevity versus oh this we've got an
endless supply of food coming in here we
can just shut everything down because we
don't have to worry about it right think
of it this way when we're young our
defenses are on hyper alert our bodies
don't get diseases you don't find babies
with Alzheimer's disease their cells
know how to repair and and defend
against issues by eating a lot of meat I
think what you're likely to be doing is
accelerating that process towards older
age so because your body will ya be in a
growth state but you won't be turning on
your body's defenses and actually as you
get older your defenses go down and down
and down and that's one of the main
reasons that we end up getting old okay
so you've got to get your defences up
like you're a baby speaking of which
I've been on on much healthier diet the
last few years including intermittent
fasting including the supplements that
I've got written
page 304 one of the people say oh I'm
not noticing anything after you know
maybe two weeks on the unsummon of
course you're not gonna see that I've
been doing it for some of them for ten
years but what I've noticed most
recently with my current lifestyle all
of these things combined the biggest
things that that has changed for me is
that I don't get sick anymore
that's amazing I used to be the kind of
guy that would go from one cold to
another I even had a sniffle in years I
can't remember the last time I had a
cold and I'm on planes people are
sneezing on me I'm shaking hands at
people pretty much all the time so my
immune system must be on hyper alert and
why is that good if you ask a
centenarian what about your younger
years in your 50s 60s they'll say I
never got sick never got a cold my
father's like that he doesn't get colds
even yeah what about sleep have you
looked at the impact of sleep on all of
this some people have well we we've done
a little bit in mice what we've
discovered is that the sort to ins that
we work on these protectors that respond
to the NAD levels in our body they cycle
through the day and they're actually
controlling our sleep/wake cycle that's
really fascinating because what it means
is that longevity protectors these
adversity sensing genes are also
controlling our body's clock uh-huh and
if you're screwing up your longevity
defenses you're also probably screwing
up your body's clock yeah so another a
side effect that I get with this new
lifestyle is I get much better sleep and
I know that you know we've got rings
that can tell us that now and I feel
great I don't wake up tired anymore the
so this nem MPT gene we talked about
earlier the one that makes nad that's
actually going up and down in levels
throughout the day goes up in the
morning gown it's changing the nad
levels and and if you get that out of
whack we get this thing we call jetlag
mm-hmm and another side effect actually
I find it anecdotally it's not proven is
that if I raise my nanny levels either
by fasting exercising or taking a
supplement I don't get the effects of
jetlag that's interesting
that's a super interesting
all right so fasting trying to create
some or missus in your life basically
living up Blue Zones lifestyle in terms
of supplementation you know I know
you're not gonna give like you know
specific recommendations but basically
walking through what you do you take a
daily resveratrol you take an nmn
supplement which is basically a
supplement oriented around promoting NID
correct correct a different version of
that would be NR right which is like one
step removed from that same process yeah
so the body uses NR which is short for
nicotinamide right aside it'll convert n
R into n MN and then n MN into nad and
that last step know that first step is
this an amputee gene aha okay so yeah
you can people are taking in are or
they're taking in a man in our is a
little cheaper than any man I've studied
any men people ask me why not in our
well any man first of all is more stable
on the shelf so that's good but also I
find that it produces some better
effects in mice when say for endurance
but the truth is even though there's a
lot of chatter on the internet and some
of my colleagues have their stakes in
some companies I by the way I don't
benefit from any supplements ever so I
have no stake in this but some of my
colleagues and on the internet they're
saying all one is better than the other
the truth is we really don't know yet
which is better or if it if they're the
same I will take any man because AI have
a ready supply because we're doing
clinical trials but also because I've
studied it the most mm-hmm and that's it
right there's no other or is there
anything else that you're taking yeah
yeah there's a there's a bit of a list
I'm also taking a drug ooh a drug a drug
called metformin which is the rise yeah
so metformin has been around since the
1970s and been in tens of millions
people it's relatively safe it's not
perfect it's not totally risk-free but
most people what they experience is an
upset stomach and
lack of appetite which can be mitigated
by a slow-release tablet you do need a
doctor's prescription in the u.s. to get
it or in Canada or an Australia or the
UK other parts of the world you can just
go buy it at a pharmacy because it's on
the list of the World Health
Organization's list of essential
medicines for Humanity so what prompted
you to get on metformin oh yeah really
simple my best friend told me to to take
it no but in all seriousness so his
name's NIR Barzilai he's considered the
world's expert in this but you know I
don't just do what my friends say I have
to research this so I looked at the
literature and there are a couple of
studies that I cite in the book they're
worth reading don't just take my word
for it
if you look at over a hundred thousand
people some cases they're veterans but
mostly older people of all walks of life
who have taken metformin because of
their type 2 diabetes high blood sugar
if you look at other diseases over the
next I think it's five years time those
that have a high risk of Alzheimer's who
don't take met Foreman have a much
higher risk of Alzheimer's than those
that took metformin and the same is true
for some cancers and frailty and heart
disease so what is that interplay like
why would that be the case right well
there's a lot of debate about how
metformin works
the main explanation is that there's an
enzyme called AMPK or a MP kinase that
talk to the sirtuin so they're actually
interplay and actually mTOR so if there
are three main anti-aging pathways I've
talked about sirtuins that we worked on
in yeast and now in mammals the middle
one is the NPK which metformin works on
and in this mTOR which responds to low
amounts of protein and they all talk to
each other so we used to fight as
scientists my pathway is more important
than your pathway blah blah blah and it
was vicious people were trying to kill
each other now we realize that there's a
network and if you tweak one you can
tweak the you'll tweak the other but I
think what the best is to tweak them
both just at moderate levels and get the
best anyway NPK what it does to the body
is it for one thing main thing is it
ramps up energy production mitochondria
like
it's called mitochondria most people may
have heard our the battery packs of the
cell and the more you exercise and if
you fast calorie restrict you'll have
more mitochondria that's a good thing
mmm that as far as I know it is you
can't have too many mitochondria that's
the key to being a good endurance
athlete mitochondrial density it is it
really is and actually as we get older
we lose about half of them attic Andreea
but one way to boost that is to take med
foreman or two to do these other things
like exercise but it's not all good news
there are some studies that show that
metformin can interfere with endurance
and muscle hypertrophy and there's been
a lot of talk about it actually on the
internet peter attea has done some some
work podcasts on this NIR Barzilai my
good friend at Albert Einstein College
of Medicine was on that study so I I
called him up and I said what's the
skinny on this tell me and he said it's
overblown and so when you look at the
data and I'm gonna be using my hands for
graphs but basically the the two bar
graphs are overlapping there's some
minor differences but there are plenty
of people in that study that took
metformin that gained more muscle than
those that didn't but overall on average
there was a slight grow slight increase
in muscle mass in those that weren't
taking metformin and doing weights but
there were benefits to the metformin
there was lower inflammation lower
oxidative stress in the people that took
the drug so what do I think is the
take-home message number one it don't
panic if you're an average person if you
don't make a living from bodybuilding
it's not gonna matter that much but in
an abundance of caution what I do is I
don't take mid for men on days I work
out pretty simple solution but I still
think on days where I'm not working out
mid Foreman's gonna protect me against
these major diseases so your impetus to
get on metformin didn't have to do with
elevated blood glucose or insulin
resistance it was pure it was more from
this sort of longevity self experiment
perspective well it's both you know
there's never a one answer to these
things my father and his father and
myself were susceptible to obesity
diabetes I'd be I'd be twice my weight
if I ate what I felt like eating and my
son struggles with this a lot he's 12
and it already struggling so we've got
obesity genes and my father went on
metformin years ago and I think is one
of the reasons he's probably still
healthy so that's that's also a fact or
no question that I took that into
account I didn't take med Forman before
I got diabetes until recently because I
just wasn't sure it was worth the risk
versus the reward but when I dug into
the science of this it was a no brainer
the risk for me is very low the worst
that I get is an upset stomach and
actually I feel less hungry so that's a
side effect that I like and then on the
up side is some of the chances of
getting I forget which type of cancer
but it's in the book can be lowered by
40% now that's a massive massive effect
so you always got to balance that so I
don't prescribe anything to people and
then what I would recommend to do is to
think what at risk am I willing to take
what are the potential downsides and
with a drug that's been in millions of
people there's a risk but the risk is
pretty low how old am I you know if I'm
110 I've probably only got two more
years so what's they lose so that's
obviously a calculation and then how
expensive is it right some some of these
things are still just very new to the
market and all of that has led to me
adapting my life over the years
admittedly some of these discoveries are
fairly new so I haven't been doing them
longer than I would have preferred to
have done them earlier but that's the
calculation and so I think that we all
know what's gonna happen in the end if
we don't do anything if we just sit
around and do what you know we think
feels comfortable the end is not pretty
I've seen what happens the other thing
that that I want to talk about I'll just
mention at least is is smoking so my
mother died of lung cancer it was brutal
to see her pass away she had a lung
removed her and she did and then a final
lung gave out 20 years later so she
lived for 20 years on one lung
she did it she managed to live a pretty
good life she visited about 18 countries
after that but the way that she passed
away I don't know if have you ever seen
someone die mm-hmm no not in that way
yeah I've never seen someone die except
my mother but she basically was was
drowning in her own fluid and it
happened pretty quickly so all I had a
chance to do was to whisper in her ear
while she was choking to death that I
wanted to thank her for being the best
mother I could ever hope for now a lot
of people die like that
do not smoke if you smoke please please
try to give up because it's not pretty
and not only are you increasing your
chance of lung cancer smoking will age
you we know that that clock the horvath
clock is accelerated by smoking because
it's damaging the DNA and distracting
the distracting The Pianist yeah if you
could what is what's the study that you
would like to see perform like if you
could design you know the perfect human
trial for example where you could do
whatever you want what would that look
like and what would you hope to
establish well we I don't have to
imagine that we're doing design one well
so I mentioned near again NIR Barzilai
he and a number of scientists have
devised a study that the FDA has
approved as being reasonable test of
whether you can slow aging down it's
going to involve hundreds of people and
a few hospitals around the country
it's called T AME or tame what is a
target targeting aging with metformin
something anyway so that's getting under
way that I think is a very good start
the idea is to take people who are
elderly who are not yet sick and monitor
them over a period of five years and
test their frailty and their
susceptibility to diseases and if we're
right we'll be able to show with those
numbers of people that a their clock is
slowed down but be that they remain
healthier because of in this case
metformin mm-hmm but you know if I had a
billion dollars I take the top 15 drugs
or molecules or
and test those as well because otherwise
all we're left with is you know what
we're doing just trying to figure this
out ourselves and what's going on in
your lab right now like when you go back
on yeah you're working on it's pretty
darn exciting I got to say I'm very
privileged to run a lab there were good
days and bad days but most good days are
my students are every few days coming to
me saying it's finally worked we've had
a breakthrough so for instance we've had
this breakthrough in reducing the cost
of this clock maybe we'll bring it down
to five or five bucks that's a great
break through that and that keeps me
happy the big thing is is reprogramming
we've now gone from slowing down aging
with resveratrol and nad boosters
reversing some aspects of aging like
endurance in mice and hopefully people
but the big thing that's just happened
over the last couple of years in the lab
and and increasingly excitingly in the
lab is the ability to replace the
pianist that's gone demented and reset
the clock and get get it to go backwards
so we we've put this paper online and
anybody in anywhere in the world can
look at it if you'd like you can go to a
place called bio archive VI o R XIV okay
mm-hmm if you type in reprogramming in
my name Sinclair you'll probably find it
too will link it up in the show notes
great so we're very proud of that that
paper which is still under review so it
hasn't hit the media actually I gotta
say I know I'm rambling hibbett podcasts
are a fantastic way of getting news out
before the actual news people figured
out so you're hearing it here first but
we hope that by sometime early this year
maybe by June we'll have this published
we were revising it for the journal
Nature which is the one of the top in
the world we're excited that we got good
reviews from our colleagues who do blind
or anonymous peer review that's a long
way of saying we are pushing the
boundary of this reprogramming method
just a quickly a nice track does that
study is what yeah
yes yeah so the summary is that those
methyl groups that are counting that we
use to count the clock we can tell the
cell to
move the right ones so that they that
the cell remembers how to play its
genome correctly like it was young there
are three genes that we we take from out
of the book of embryos so when you're an
embryo you're using three particular
genes to to grow and be healthy they get
switched off by the time we're young
adults even while they're babies if you
put them back in just at the right time
in the right place at the right moment
we found that it's it's rope we don't
see any safety issues so that's the good
thing what we see is the clock gets
wound backwards those methyl groups go
back long story short the cells are
reprogrammed to be young again
completely not just a little bit not 2%
not two years but we can take it for
example in this paper you'll see if
anyone looks at it can take mice that
have gone blind from old age if we put
these three genes into the eye and turn
them on for a few weeks
their vision comes back as though they
were young again what that tells me is
that a lot of what we regard as a
one-way street in aging is reversible if
we can restore eyesight what else can we
reverse I mean that's got to be about as
exciting as it gets right I mean yeah
I've seen a lot of amazing Wow and and
our colleagues and I have to credit we
have a lot of help I don't know my way
around a mouse's eye to save my life but
our colleagues that did these
experiments with us they blown away my
colleague Bruce Cassandra at a Massiah
near Hospital in Boston he called me up
at 10:30 at night and he said David you
wouldn't believe what we've just seen
excuse the pun we've got restoration of
vision I want to run down tomorrow and
tell the FDA this is possible because
right now degenerative eye diseases like
glaucoma macular degeneration these are
not reversible the best you can do is
slow them down slightly anyway that
that's a whole story but what we're now
trying to figure out in my lab is how is
it possible to reset the cell how does
that work and where is the reset switch
what what's the repository of the
information
put another way where's the backup hard
drive of the cell right so when that
analogue system gets scratched there's
an ability to
reboot it with you know a digital
replicant that is perfect yeah and we
don't know where that information
resides we know we can tap into it by
using these three genes called OS and K
for short but how that works and where
it goes to find the old information to
be young it could be a chemical on the
DNA it could be a protein that sticks to
DNA for our whole lives we're actively
searching and so we got a whole bunch of
very smart people in my lab look working
hard on that and obviously you know
human beings are infinitely more complex
than mice but what can you extrapolate
from that to give you confidence about
applicability and in in a human context
right well we we don't know but we do
work in human cells so we can take human
neurons and grow them making mini brain
in the dish and we can both accelerate
aging make the penis demented in those
cells and we can reverse the age of
those cells and make them grow again
like they were young so we've done it
what we say in vitro in the dish we've
done it in mice our eyes and our
biological systems aren't any different
than a mouse's really so I'm optimistic
you know but until we know in humans so
we can do this I can't declare victory
so what I'm doing as I typically do is
try to spin out the technology get it
into patients as safely and as fast as
possible
but in hopefully in the next few years
we'll have the first patient tested and
the results will be pretty quick this
isn't like a long term longevity study
if we can restore vision to a patient
with glaucoma we should know within a
few weeks and I would imagine that I
mean basically you're dealing with a
reversal mechanism so there's no reason
to believe that it would only be
operational in you know and in the optic
context like it should it should be
applicable across the board or in other
you know respect to other problem you
are exactly right we didn't choose the
eye because it was easy we chose it
because it was hard and because the eye
gets old very quickly if you damage your
eye so I'm gonna grow back like your
skin so we thought let's go for it
my student one chain lose is a brave
brave student so if we can do that to
the I are much more optimistic that
these other organs and systems whether
it be a kidney that's failing or a liver
skin who knows we keep we're gonna test
that rigorous here we can even try it to
reprogram the entire animal we've
started doing that one of the now you're
just getting crazy right
well you got to do it I'm sorry everyone
else to know the answer but but here's
what's holding us back in in the
technology the ability to deliver genes
is not as easy as everyone thinks there
it is right now there are some drugs on
the market that can actually fix genetic
diseases in blood and in the eye but
trying to get gene therapy to the rest
of the body is still a challenge and so
one of the things we're working on and
having some success is being able to
deliver it to every cell in the body or
nearly every cell in the body and not
have it all concentrated in the liver
which is typically where these genes go
when you deliver them IV but ultimately
imagine a world let let's be a little
bit of dreamers here if my colleagues
will allow me imagine a world where you
you have these three genes put into your
body let's say at 50 and then you're
basically like Deadpool if you get
injured you can have an IV turn on these
genes heal better you lose your eyesight
turn it on in the eye fix your eye
who knows what have an AVO whole body
rejuvenation that would be pretty
interesting and we've only reset aging
once in the eye we don't know if you can
do it twice we don't know if you do it
10 times or infinitely mm-hmm what more
will be revealed we will come back I'll
come back and tell you how things going
yeah please do we're all counting on you
you have that civilization rests on your
shoulders the future of all of us will
end in the meantime seat of your lab
there's a lot we can do to stay healthy
for longer and actually that every year
you are alive you get an extra three
months of life because technology's
changing that's encouraging that's gonna
that's gonna like allow us to end this
on an optimistic note I think thank you
super interesting I really have so much
respect for the work that you're doing
you did a beautiful job with this book
there's so much to learn and I know that
you're at the cutting edge of learning
it for all of us so come back and keep
us up to date on everything that's going
on I'd love to yeah thank you so much
pick up the book lifespan support local
booksellers if you can't find it at your
local bookseller tell them to order it
for you or go to Amazon yeah right
wherever good books is sold and david is
easy to find on the internet it's just
at David Sinclair PhD on one Instagram
on Instagram yeah it's a series David a
Sinclair cool awesome man anybody
anything else you want to let people
know about before we end it here let's
all celebrate 80 years from now that
sounds good man it's a plan whose
where's the party gonna be your house I
think we'll do it your house alright
good
Thank You Man
[Music]
you